Master Wayne learn on imaging is showing
me two dozen hostiles on the third floor
why don't I drop you off on the second
I'm getting slower with my old age
effort even you got too old to die young
not for lack of trying
he has the power to wipe out the entire
human race and we believe there's even a
1% chance that he is our enemy we have
to take it as an absolute sir the
greatest gladiator match in the history
of the world God versus man
day versus night you psychotic it was a
three syllable word for any thought too
big for little minds
now if you wouldn't like you
whoo I don't think you've ever known a
woman like me
the oldest line America
but power can be innocent
blade
you will rated pg-13
today is a day for truth the world needs
to know what happened and to know what
he stands for that kind of power is very
dangerous
let the record show that this committee
holds him responsible
that's how it starts the fever the rage
of turns good men cruel
this bat vigilantes like a one-man right
of terror you don't get to decide what
the right thing is nobody cares about
Clark Kent taking on the Batman
this means something to all some people
have it's all that gives them hope
people hate what they don't understand
be their hero Clark be their
Joel beer monument
be anything they need you
won't be none of it
you don't owe this world a thing you
never did do you know the oldest lie in
America senator the devil's don't come
from Hell beneath us
they come from the sky
twenty years in Gotham I make good guys
are left
and I stayed that way he has the power
to wipe out the entire human race
I'm gonna have to destroy him
you're gonna go to war
he is not our enemy
black and blue
God versus man
day versus night
the red capes are coming
the red capes are coming
rated pg-13 this bat vigilante it's like
a one-man right of terror
the press has to do the right thing you
don't get to decide what the right thing
is nobody cares about Clark Kent taking
on the Batman
next time they shine your light in the
sky don't go to it the bat is dead bury
it
pg-13
is it really surprising that the most
powerful man in the world should be a
figure of controversy we as a population
on this planet have been looking for a
savior name we're talking about a Bailey
whose very existence you're not telling
us the truth challenge is our own sense
of priority in the universe human beings
have a horrible track record of
following people with great power
corrupts and absolute power corrupts
absolutely chaos maybe he's just a guy
trying to do the right little better now
Delma Devil's don't come from Hell
beneath I thought their warrior they
come from the sky the world has been so
caught up with what he can do that no
one has asked what he should do that's
how it starts the fever the rage the
feeling of powerlessness that turns good
men
cruel
tell me do you plead
you will
you're gonna go to wall he's the one
that brought the war to us count the
dead thousands of people what's next
millions he has the power to wipe out
the entire human race and if we believe
there's even a 1% chance that he is our
enemy we have to take it as an absolute
sir now I have to destroy him rated
pg-13 is it really surprising that the
most powerful man in the world should be
a figure of controversy we as a
population on this planet have been
looking for a savior we're talking about
a being whose very existence you're not
telling us the truth challenges our own
sense of priority in the universe human
beings have a horrible track record of
following people with great power
corrupts and absolute power corrupts
absolutely hey maybe he's just a guy
trying to do the right little better now
don't we Devil's don't come from
I brought their warrior they come from
the sky the world has been so caught up
with what he can do that no one has
asked what he should do that's how it
starts the fever the rage the feeling of
powerlessness that turns good men
cool
tell me do you plead
you will
miss away Clark Kent Daily Planet civil
liberties are being trampled on in their
city the bat vigilante thinks he's above
the law don't believe everything you
hear something
boys Bruce Wayne meets Clark Kent I love
it I love bringing people together Lex
it is a pledge out wow that is a good
grip you should not pick a fight with
this person where the pg-13
today is a day for truth the world needs
to know what happened and to know what
he stands for that kind of power is very
dangerous
let the record show that this committee
holds him responsible
that's how it starts the fever the rage
of turns good men cruel this bat
vigilantes like a one-man right of
terror you don't get to decide what the
right thing is nobody cares about Clark
Kent taking on the Batman
this means something all some people
have it's all that gives them hope
people hate what they don't understand
be their hero Clark be their angel be
their monument
be anything they need you feel or be
none of it
you don't owe this world a thing you
never did do you know the oldest lie in
America senator the devil's don't come
from Hell beneath us
they come from the sky
twenty years in Gotham I make good guys
are left
I'm gonna stayed that way he has the
power to wipe out the entire human race
I'm gonna have to destroy him
you're gonna go to war
he is not our enemy
black and blue
God versus man
day versus night
the red capes are coming the red capes
are coming
super manga how can you so matter you're
gonna go to war standard only say I do
need a superhero
Seanie gifted
stay down but wanted it you'd be dead
already
time you learned what it means to be a
man
but c'mon do you super who's there you
must be new
that is first Wain
this away Clark Kent Daily Planet what's
your position on the Baths vigilante in
Gotham
civil liberties are being trampled on in
their city people living in fear
thinks he's above the law a Daily Planet
criticizing those who think they're
above the laws don't hypocritical once
yourself considering every time your
hero saves a cat out of tree you read
off-piste editorial about an alien you
could burn the whole place down most of
the world doesn't share your opinion mr.
Wayne
maybe it's Gotham City and me you just
have a bad history with freaks dressed
like clowns
boys hmm Bruce Wayne meets Clark Kent I
love it
I love bringing people together how are
we Thanks hi hello Lex it is a pledge
out wow that is a good grip you should
not pick a fight with this person you
know the oldest lie in America senator
the power can be innocent
you're gonna go to war
as some [ __ ] brought the war true of us
you know you can't win this it's suicide
the greatest gladiator match in the
history of the world
Son of Krypton versus bat of Gotham
you're psychotic
there's a three syllable word for any
thought too big for little minds
Stein you learn what it means to be a
man lay down
I wanted it you be dead already
man will kill God
the piano will do it
what have you done
ha
he with you I thought yours with you
power corrupts and absolute power
corrupts absolutely you're gonna go to
war this may be the only thing I do
the greatest gladiator match in the
history of the world Son of Krypton
versus bat of Gotham stay down
I wanted it you'd be dead already Sam
you learned what it means to be a man
miss away Clark Kent Daily Planet what's
your position on the bat vigilante in
Gotham boys hmm Bruce Wayne meets Clark
Kent I love it I love bringing people
together do you know the oldest lie in
America that power can be innocent
you're gonna go to war
he's the one that brought the war to us
you know you can't win this it's suicide
the greatest gladiator match in the
history of the world Son of Krypton
versus bat of Gotham
what have you done
Oh